in recent years the united states and
our allies in western europe have
peddled lots of far-left causes onto the
rest of the world from climate change
hysteria to transgender ideology to
other radical social movements
but it turns out the rest of the world
countries in africa in asia and
elsewhere
don't really like those leftist hobby
horses all that much
increasingly they're turning to our
geopolitical adversaries including china
and russia
for help and leadership in stopping the
tide of radicalism
all of which is leading american
conservatives to an unsettling question
have we become the baddies
i'm michael nolsas the michael knowles
ship
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from mcl black who
says funny the wnba parade looks about
like a biden press conference
that's no that's not fair it looks like
abiding campaign rally at the press
conferences at least there are usually
some people there they don't get any
answers and biden runs away but at the
biden rallies that's where really you
can see the tumbleweed just start to
roll past the screen
the political instability is enough to
make you want to hedge your investments
which is why i would strongly recommend
you check out acre gold i have really
enjoyed investing in physical precious
metals in my life especially in gold
but i know what people are thinking
you're thinking michael
gold is expensive i can't afford
physical gold michael all right i didn't
write a blank book michael i don't have
okay calm down come you don't need to
make this personal
do you have thirty dollars if you have
thirty dollars you can start investing
in physical gold you're a liar michael
no i'm not a liar i'm not acre has
figured it out for as little as 30 bucks
a month you can invest in physical gold
you send in your 30 bucks a month when
your gold stash reaches the price of
acres gold bars they will discreetly
ship physical acre gold to your house
recently they've introduced a new
hundred dollar a month subscription to a
five gram gold bar if you want to up the
ante it ships directly it's really great
stuff
visit get acre gold dot com slash no
start investing in physical gold today
make sure you go to that url because
acre is giving away a gold bar to
qualify for the giveaway tweet or post
why you should be the recipient and
mention at get underscore acre that is
get acre gold dot com slash knowles
thank you aker gold for supporting the
show they're going after chappelle
they're going after chappelle i know
this story broke about a week ago and i
just haven't had time to get to it and
you know left winger is going after a
politically incorrect comedian that's
nothing new that's not exactly a news
story but i think it ties in with a lot
of of the other things we're seeing on
the world stage now
countries outside of america and western
europe are starting to push back against
some of the radical kooky lunatic
ideologies that we are exporting the
woke ideologies that we are exporting to
the rest of the world and dave chappelle
just came under fire because he stood up
against it
initially the ceo of netflix defended
dave chappelle
then he got a ton of backlash from
lunatics many of whom worked at his own
company and now he's sort of apologizing
for defending chappelle so the first
question i actually haven't seen the
chappelle special yet not because i
don't want to i like chappelle well
enough i really like that he's got a
little tribute to norm mcdonald at the
end of it i just i just haven't had time
so i haven't watched i finally i said
what did this guy say
to lead to all of these protests and it
turns out what dave chappelle said is
that
i can't i can't believe we got to do
another show on it
he said that men are not women
she said
gender was a fact
and then the trans community got mad
they started calling her a turf i didn't
even know what that was
but i know that trans people make up
words to win arguments
so i looked it up
turf is an acronym
stands for trans-exclusionary radical
feminists this is a real thing this is a
group of women
that hate transgender they don't hate
transgender women but they look at trans
women the way we blacks might look at
blackface it offends them like this is
doing an impression of me
i'm team turf
i agree
i agree man
gender is a fact you have to look at it
from a woman's perspective
it's a fact it's a simple statement
dave chappelle is not a right winger
he's not a conservative i don't think
he's a christian
he and i probably disagree on many if
not most things
but we do agree on this and this
shouldn't be
the shocking kumbaya moment that it has
become
until about five minutes ago everyone
agreed that men are not women and then
starting i don't know what like 2017 or
something
the left in this country lost its mind
and now pretends that men are women but
what's interesting to me is not the
argument dave's making we all know we
all know that that's true what's
interesting is the reactions the ceo
comes out he initially said quote while
some employees disagree we have a strong
belief that content on screen does not
directly translate to real world harm
ah
i'm glad that he defended chappelle i'm
glad he didn't at least initially give
in to the kooks and the lunatics at his
own company protesting him
but what he said is not true
conservatives don't
believe that that's true he said we
don't believe that the content on screen
translates to real world harm so what
you're saying is you don't believe that
cultural products have real world
implications right that's that's kind of
the broader version of what of what this
guy said
but that's not true for how long have
conservatives said politics is
downstream of culture for how long have
conservatives said we need to take back
hollywood and take back the academy and
take back the press and take back the
publishing and how long have we said
that
we say that because we believe that
cultural content does have real world
implications
you know this is parodied as this idea
that in the 90s mothers were very
concerned that kids would start shooting
up schools because they played violent
video games and
the right was kind of split on this yes
the video games matter no the video
games don't matter oh it's cool you know
you see this with the debate with porn
well just because kids are watching a
ton of porn doesn't mean they're going
to have disordered sexual relationships
no come on but
if you
believe in any way that politics is
downstream of culture or if you at least
believe that culture kind of matters in
politics then surely what this ceo of
netflix said is not true
so the lunatics protesting him knew that
that was not true and they kept going
after him kept going after him now he
says i screwed up the internal
communication i did that i screwed it up
in two ways first and foremost i should
have led with a lot more humanity i had
a group of employees who were definitely
feeling pain and hurt from a decision we
made and i think that needs to be
acknowledged up front before you get
into the nuts and bolts of anything i
didn't do that then he goes on to point
out yeah there are real world
implications from the cultural products
first of all he led with humanity okay
what the left is saying here that is not
true
is that it's inhumane and cruel to tell
deluded men that they're not really
women okay that they their argument is
that it's not nice and compassionate
to tell people the truth if they happen
to be confused and that's not true at
all it's actually very disrespectful and
cruel to lie to people so what dave
chappelle did and what the netflix guy
did at least initially was very humane
it was very compassionate it was very
respectful to tell people the truth
now he's going squishy because that's
that's what happens there are three
takes on the chappelle fiasco
i notice on a lot of news stories there
were three takes
that that one really can have there's
the lib take
the far left i'm sorry the leftist take
which is
that dave chappelle needs to be silenced
and shut up and netflix should never
have done this and they should they
should delete the comedy special now
then there is the kind of lib
libertarian take which is dave chappelle
has the right to say whatever he damn
well pleases and how dare you squash
free speech and engage in censorship
he should be able to say whatever's on
his mind
then there is the conservative take
which is that dave chappelle absolutely
has the right to say true things
i don't think dave chappelle has the
right to say whatever he wants
i don't think dave chappelle has the
right to threaten people i don't think
dave chappelle has the right to engage
in fighting words i don't think dave
chappelle has the right to slander
people i don't think dave chappelle has
the right to
engage in obscenity
to engage in obscene speech certainly
doesn't have the right to do any of that
sort of stuff
he does have the right to say the truth
and he did just tell the truth here and
the truth is that men are not women
right so he has the right to do that so
the libertarians and the conservatives
are on the same page with regard to
whether or not to take down the david
chabelle special
but
really the conservatives and the woke
people are on the same page when it
comes to the observation that there are
limits to speech okay
and
what the what the woke people want to
push
is they they say that you have the right
to say false things and you don't have
the right to say true things
and the conservatives say you have the
right to say true things but you don't
necessarily have the right to say false
things and the libertarians and the
squishes in the middle
refuse to distinguish between true and
false or good and bad or right and wrong
how has that worked out we we have taken
the libertarian squish approach for the
last 30 or so years how has that worked
out
not looking great by my lights the fact
that we even have to debate this the
fact that this is even controversial
that men are not women shows you that
the squish libertarian approach has not
worked so now you have two choices you
either go with the woke approach
which insists upon lies and bans the
truth or you get the conservative
approach which insists upon the truth
and is not so polite to lies and that
requires us to have the
conscience and the reason to be able to
discern truth from falsehood
and it requires us to have the
intestinal and spinal and maybe some
other kind of anatomical fortitude to
actually stand by the truth and enforce
it
dave chappelle is a turf he's a turf
has he said a thing that's true
you are seeing this right now on the
right
it's not just me pushing it i'm i may
have been uh
among the voices crying out in the
wilderness
[Music]
on this particular issue before but i
think now this is kind of the mainstream
view and you're seeing it playing out at
the level of the governors and the
senators and
it turns the more willing
conservatives are to make a distinction
between true and false and right and
wrong and actually wield government
power it seems the better position they
are for 2024 if i ask you right now
who which which governor at least is
best positioned
for the 2024 presidential race it's not
it wouldn't take you two seconds it's
ron desantis
and it is no coincidence that ron
desantis right now in florida
it's not just reciting the same old
shallow
false platitudes from late 90s
republican pamphlets that say that we
should never use government power and we
should just you know let let rich woke
people do whatever they want
ron desantis is willing to use the
government for good
ends you know when when people are
in the midst of this social and
political craziness they want to keep
their money safe which is why i would
strongly recommend you check out alto
ira alto ira gives you a better way to
invest in crypto a lot of people think
cryptocurrency might represent the
future of money it's one of the most
exciting investment opportunities to
come around for some time
but what about taxes
right when you want to do anything in
life there's one way to do it and then
maybe there's a smarter way to do it
okay so you might already be investing
in crypto but did you know that you can
trade bitcoin ethereum over 80 other
cryptocurrencies in a tax advantaged ira
with an alto crypto ira you can trade
crypto like bitcoin and avoid or defer
the taxes get into investing in crypto
and do it in a tax advantaged retirement
account you can create an account in
just a few minutes you can start
investing with as little as 10 bucks
zero setup charges there are a bunch of
ways to fund your account you can do it
with a cash contribution transfer cash
from an existing ira roll over an old
401 k a lot of ways to do it open an
alto crypto ira account with as little
as 10 bucks go to alto altoira dot com
slash michael m-i-c-h-a-e-l that is
a-l-t-o-i-r-a dot com slash michael
altoira dot com slash michael
ron desantis
i think the first or certainly one of
the first states to reopen
after the covet lockdowns
he gave businesses a lot of liability
protection in order to do that
right
he he said look you we're open for
business in florida but you can't go
around suing people if you catch covid
right the businesses are open
and the business owners really liked
that
right but now they're getting some
pushback from the woke people they're
getting some pushback from the biden
administration and so they are not
willing to offer that same
courtesy to their customers or to their
employees
right now there are businesses in
florida that are trying they're
mandating that the employees get
these experimental drugs about covid and
ron desantis is using the government
to punish businesses and to
disincentivize businesses
from doing that
what we're going to be doing in addition
to
mounting
aggressive legal challenges to federal
mandates uh we're also going to be
taking legislative action uh to add
protections for people in the state of
florida and that that's something that
cannot wait until the regular
legislative session next year um it
needs to happen soon and so we will be
calling the legislature back
for a special session
we're going to be pursuing a number of
protections
for employees uh first of all if you
think about it if anyone has been forced
uh to do an injection and has an adverse
reaction that business should be liable
for that any damages there's just
you have to do it because that's on them
it wasn't an individual choice
once again there are three positions
here there's the woke position which is
yeah let's let's use osha and the
federal government and the businesses to
make the businesses mandate that the
employees get the vaccine right yeah
anything to inject you with the fouchy
algae then there's the libertarian view
which is well it's a private business
and the business can do whatever it
wants and it's bad if the government
injects you with the drug but it's not
bad if the business injects you with the
drug and you know just start your own
corporation or whatever and then there's
the conservative view which is
this
experimental drug
has side effects some of which have been
pretty serious
it does not have any long-term data to
go along with it there are some studies
that suggest that there could be really
negative consequences for groups of
people who take it the virus itself does
not pose a particularly grave danger to
the vast majority of people
and there are a lot of questions about
natural immunity and
people's own risks here so because of
that we're going to take the cautious
prudential measure to not
uh using dubious legal mechanisms and
power companies to zap you full of an
experimental drug
it's a long way of giving the
conservative point of view but i just
want to point out how reasonable and
prudential it is that's what desantis is
doing
okay desantis is saying
i'm not any happier about having my
rights and way of life taken away
if it's taken away by a corporation than
it is by the government
the ideologues
on on the squish kind of libertarian-ish
side
they're the ones who say yeah i don't
care
shoot me with the fouchyache just don't
let it be the government
all hail big corporations
a conservative view no we're not going
to do that so just as ron desantis
gave businesses a huge amount of freedom
in the early part of the covid lockdowns
now he is prudently wielding the
government to protect the freedoms of
employees and of the people and to have
just government really good stuff very
good use of state power
and of course he's going to be called an
authoritarian
that word more than almost any other
word i would strike that word from the
english language because i don't think
it really means anything anymore
by the current use of authoritarianism
on the left and on the right
thomas jefferson would be an
authoritarian john locke would be an
authoritarian what does that mean if you
have
any
limits at all to people's individual
autonomy to what to do drugs to to sleep
with whoever they want to force your
employees to take
experimental shots to what any
everything
anything i don't like is
authoritarianism in today's day and age
well they're calling desantis and
authoritarian speaking of authoritarians
looking overseas
i'm turning to russia for a moment and i
notice
that while boris johnson the allegedly
conservative prime minister in the uk
is pushing for a massive climate change
summit where they're going to push a
bunch of crazy hysteria about the sun
monster and the u.s is for it and a lot
of western europe is for it
vladimir putin in russia says i'm not
going to go
now we on the conservative side were
accused of collaborating and colluding
with the russians some years ago we were
accused of that by the deep state and uh
liars in our federal agencies and based
on nothing but now i'm starting to think
maybe we should start colluding with
these russians you know maybe these
russians at least on the topic of the
sun monster they seem to have a better
idea and the the power grab being pushed
by boris johnson and other western
leaders including our own i think putin
probably has the right idea here
putin apparently just funded this
cathedral there's an amazing military
cathedral just opened recently in russia
it's beautiful beautiful architecture
it's probably the
one example of new beautiful
architecture with the you know a deep
cultural and religious basis a minute i
thought i said maybe we've got to start
colluding with these russians
because they got the right idea i don't
i don't think the russians exactly have
our interests at heart
you know i wouldn't uh but i would like
it maybe if our leaders here in the woke
west
took a couple notes perhaps from
from putin even more authoritarian than
putin xi jinping the leader of china is
also ditching
this this ridiculous summit that boris
johnson is putting
putting on and people in other countries
around the world who are resisting the
tyranny of uh
you know the the sun monster technocracy
first you had the kovid technocracy and
now they're they're trying to
maintain their recently acquired power
by pretending that the new existential
threat is the sun monster well a lot of
other countries are looking
to other nations for leadership now
where they once might have looked to the
united states they're looking to other
nations because they don't want to
import these kooky woke ideologies like
transgenderism
or climate hysteria
you see this right now in an article
from the ap
ap just came out with an article across
africa major churches strongly oppose
lgbtq rights and when they say lgbtq
rights they mean redefining marriage in
a way that you know marriage for all of
human history everywhere in the world
involved sexual difference right maybe
some places tolerated polygamy
some places in the christian west did
not tolerate polygamy
but sexual difference was
thought to have maybe something to do
with marriage now five minutes ago in
the west we decided that isn't true and
we still we really don't know what
marriage is now anymore we've we've
settled on this idea that it's a
monogamous well no not necessarily
because there's polyamory and all of
this sort of stuff but that it's a union
of two people of any sex who love each
other but they don't love each other the
way that siblings love each other and
they don't love each other the way that
friends love each other they love each
other in this
more romantic way but it's but for some
reason it's only two people
for now but maybe it'll be three people
we don't really know what it is so
the the article begins in ghana home to
a diverse array of religions leaders of
major churches have united in denouncing
homosexuality as a perversion and
endorsing legislation that would impose
anti-lgbt policies
and then they go through all of these
plate nigeria is not down with
redefining marriage and in other african
countries bishops aligned with the
worldwide united methodist church are
preparing to join an in the works
breakaway denomination so they can
continue their practice of refusing to
recognize same-sex marriage or ordain
lgbtq
clergy and it goes on to complain about
how these africans won't accept woke
western secular ideologies you'll notice
here they don't they don't talk about
the catholic church because the catholic
church has not changed its view because
the catholic church cannot change its
view on marriage or or these sorts of
things but a lot of protestant churches
have and some protestant churches are
holding out
so another way to read
this article is
african countries
try to to maintain their own culture
and try to resist
western imperialism in this case the
imperialism of the pride flag or the
progress flag or
what or it's even beyond the marriage
issue you see with abortion the west
pushes abortion on africa in a lot of
countries that don't want it or the west
pushes
all sorts of things contraception even
too
you would think that the woke people
would be in favor of the africans
keeping their own culture and opposing
western imperialism and hegemony but
they're not
because what we're seeing here is that
liberalism is is really not so much
about you do you and i'll do me and live
and let live
it's not that at all liberalism actually
appears to be a fairly totalitarian
ideology this is why we focus on the
rainbow flag as the kind of new flag of
the united states
is the flag of the united states the
stars and stripes is a national flag
that talks about the nation of america
which is a bounded concept the lgbt the
rainbow flag is a an imperial flag it's
a universal flag the claims of the
rainbow are just as true in tibet as
they are in detroit right this is a flag
for all people at all times throughout
history
and the state department is pushing this
imperial ideology
the state department just yesterday
tweeted out its support of international
pronouns day
state department tweets out yesterday
quote today on international pronouns
day we share why so many people list
pronouns on their email and social media
profiles read more here
that's great we we really support
pronouns and people and men pretending
to be women
right this is what it says actually
underneath you can read it in the post
read on to learn why it matters what
pronouns you use to refer to people and
how the united states embraces sharing
pronouns so
there are two questions here or two
possibilities i guess to the question
why why is america sharing this is it
because america is just oblivious to how
radical this idea is that men can be
women and it's important to pretend that
men are women in some cases
or is it because the u.s state
department knows that this is a
poisonous but very effective ideology
and the united states is wepping it
weaponizing it to increase our power and
influence around the world
i don't know i don't know
i suspect it's some combination actually
i suspect that most of the pawns who are
pushing this just think it's just true
it's just true that men can be women we
it's just good to do that and i suspect
a lot of people at the top recognize
that it's a powerful ideological weapon
it's an information weapon
either way though
it is authoritarian it is an imperial
ideology and people do have the right to
resist it
you know back when the united states
stood for truth justice in the american
way
back when we were a christian nation in
our self-understanding back when the
west broadly was christendom
i think a lot of us could get on board
with
sending that overseas i mean that's that
was the point of columbus's voyage that
was the point of western exploration
just to share the good news of the
gospel and the civilization that
christianity created to the rest of the
world
and we're on i'm on board with that yeah
let's do it let's go let's bring the
good news man let's do it as a great
civilization let's share it with people
but now if the empire is going abroad to
share
transgender bathrooms and climate
hysteria and fear of the sun monster
i'm not on board with that
and i have a great deal of empathy
actually for the nations in africa or
asia or wherever else
that want to resist it people are
resisting it here the alcs was on tv the
other night
you've got a-rod and big poppy we're on
fox sports discussing the game
and the crowd
decided to start chanting a very
well-known expression a variation on the
phrase let's go brandon
guys can come in like a chest in the
queen or or a rook on the chessboard
right these people have routines but i
think if aldi's the one guy he can get
away with i thought he baldy kind of let
his hair down a little bit he threw two
unbelievable split fingers for
strikeouts for out and two
when last diaz by the way missed
one calls tonight
right the average is eight or nine for
an umpire 21 is a great deal when he
gets that call i thought he lost his
concentration and when he hung the split
kudos to a-rod for not breaking his his
commentary he keep pushing keeps pushing
right ahead but
you can hear and it's not let's go
branded that they're chanting it's the
real the real version of that
that took place outside fenway park
that took place it wasn't in south
carolina it wasn't in texas or tennessee
that was in boston
it's become a meme
and also joe biden has a very low
approval rating even in places that
might have voted for him
i think the oppressed masses
yearning to be free
want political leaders to free us from
the shackles of this libertine woke
progressive liberal madness okay and i
think that politicians republicans who
run
on the old squish way of things i'm
thinking of asa hutchinson in arkansas
or you know any number of those wishes
who run and they say if you elect me i
won't do anything
i'll never impose my views on anybody
i'm going to defend the neutral or you
know that you know the neutral political
order of transgender bathrooms you know
the neutral political order of
completely redefining marriage you know
the neutral political order of this that
and the other thing
no i think what people recognize is
there is no neutral political order all
all polities have some view of what's
good and wrong and bad and and and we
want our leaders to have a spine
okay we want them
to fight for us you're seeing this right
now speaking of sports in texas governor
abbott
just banned boys from playing in girls
sports okay cool makes perfect sense the
white house is furious this is what the
white house said quote this hateful bill
in texas is just the latest example of
republican state lawmakers using
legislation to target transgender kids
whom the president believes are some of
the bravest americans you know you know
they're just storming iwo jima in order
to score political points
these anti-transgender bills are nothing
more than bullying disguised as
legislation and undermine our nation's
core values you know
thomas jefferson's core value abraham
lincoln's core value of letting dudes go
into the girls changing room you
remember that
amazing how how fast that happened
okay it's amazing how
quickly in 2012
2011 barack obama opposed and joe biden
and everyone else opposed redefining
marriage
today if you oppose letting husky hank
go into the girls changing room with
your daughter you're a bigot
amazing how fast that happened
conservatives used to say oh don't worry
about these woke people oh don't worry
common sense will get the better of them
i don't think that's true common sense
will
will only be around if people defend it
and embrace common sense and enforce
common sense
which brings me to another favorite
politician of mine since i was a kid
but
but he's getting criticized right now
it's rudy giuliani he gets criticized
because sometimes he does things that
are eccentric so rudy just posted on on
social media this image of him this
video of him as a kind of face swapped
abraham lincoln talking about
terry mcauliffe in virginia
virginia
vote against
the man who dishonored our past by
selling my bedroom
hundreds and hundreds of times to
scoundrels
in a pay for play scheme
in my time we had a name for men who
sold bedrooms for one night in your time
the name is terry mccarth and the
clinton flees once and for all
i love this i love it i love it people
are making fun of them and they're
saying rudy seems crazy and what do you
do no please stop no i don't i'm not a
roody republican i think it's great i
think it's hilarious i think it's like
clint eastwood talking to the empty
chair
at the 2012 republican national
convention i think we need more of this
in our politics a little levity
a little humor trump was obviously the
king of this i don't want to hear any
more nitpicking of republicans who are
doing a good job and who are basically
have their heart in the right place and
are basically doing the right stuff okay
i don't margery green is kooky yeah
whatever i don't care is she doing like
good stuff is she not doing evil stuff
and is she doing good stuff and is she
trying to go in the right direction okay
that's fine by me rudy yeah rudy man
he's america's mayor that's great
got to recognize what the stakes here
folks and cut it out with the squishy
stuff all right we got to get into the
mailbag first though you know drew is
going to be talking about this cold
civil war that we appear to be in he's
going to ask if it is going to turn hot
you can check that out today also check
out the morning wire subscribe and start
listening to morning wire on apple
spotify wherever you listen to your
podcasts leave a five star review if you
like what you hear we'll be right back
with the mailbag
welcome back to my favorite time of the
week the mailbag first question up from
asher michael my name is asher i'm 16
and i have a little philosophy question
for you
imagine you live in a world where you
had everything possible that you wanted
wealth you had a perfect family
liz cheney and mitt romney voted using
conservative values
all scotus justices ruled like scalia
and thomas
and most importantly everyone used a
ring alarm system
but in order to live in this world one
person has to be humiliated and suffer
every single day you have the option to
leave this perfect life but if you do
everything you have is not guaranteed to
be the same would you leave this perfect
life where all of it is predicated on
one person being tortured every day
thanks love your show uh i would leave
that world i do not want to live in a
world
where
i benefit but only at the expense of
someone being
ruthlessly
needlessly tortured okay
this is a thought experiment that does
come up sometimes and the just answer is
that yeah you you would
you would not accept a world where you
get good stuff
but only by inflicting torture
constantly on somebody
and then sociopaths say they would just
live in the world and who cares about
the person being tortured what's
interesting about this experiment though
or this thought experiment
is its relationship to christianity
right because
this is a fallen world this is a broken
world and because of original sin sin
and death pervade the world and the
consequence of that is our mortality so
we're born and we have this wonderful
fun time and some free will but we're
going to die right and that is the
consequence of original sin
but there is good news and the good news
is that christ dies on the cross and is
crucified and
and redeems us and is resurrected and
redeems us our savior lives so happy
fault that one for us so great so glory
is a redeemer
so in a way our
eternal happiness
which is provided for through no uh
particular
uh
help of our own
this eternal happiness does hinge on the
torture the sort of infinite
uh
suffering
of christ on the cross the idea that
god himself
the the eternal
logic of the universe would be crucified
but would then conquer death
right so the greatest imaginable
suffering but would then actually
conquer death
on the cross
so
there is a real theological depth to uh
to that question
but if you're asking as an as an ethical
matter would you uh you know chain
someone up to the radiator and torture
them forever so you could have a good
life i know not a good idea from nick
good morning michael the nature of news
reporting in the original sense has
shifted dramatically in the past decades
so much so that younger people tend to
take their news from influencers on
social media not traditional news
sources
as a result influencers who have almost
no credentials in news media
cannot be held accountable if and when
they boast an influential opinion which
produces the same results traditional
news media produce
the effect of this is that in the war
for culture the liberal media has
claimed enough influencers to take the
cultural tide and the only current way
for conservatives to win the war is to
garner more influencers on social media
than the left something that is actively
being suppressed my question is is there
a way governmentally to run around the
problem to rein in influencers with the
same rules and long story short can
social media be safe from the libs
via government intervention sincerely
nick happily married one well
i think you're
overestimating the
credibility of journalists before this
happened
you know someone like walter cronkite
the most trusted journalist in america
was a gigantic lib and a world
federalist who probably lost us the
vietnam war so frankly if it's between
i don't know nicki minaj you know or
kanye west tweeting something and walter
cronkite having a
a monopoly on credibility i'm i'm with
kanye you know i i don't want to go back
to a world where walter cronkite is
trusted real or dan rather my goodness
stan brother's just a liar he's a lib
liar but he was trusted by many people
for a long time i don't want to go back
to that world i say this as an
influencer i don't have a journalism
degree i'm not i've never worked as a
reporter
i have worked as a journalist for a long
time and i've written books and i've
done shows and things like that but
i guess i'm an influencer but i i would
rather my influence be in the politics
than that of walter cronkite
now
for the suppression of the right-wing
influencers on social media can the
government be used to help yeah totally
i asked bill barthes i said how do we do
it do we do it through
claiming that
the the left is or that the big tech
companies are violating their section
230 responsibilities you know from the
communications decency act that they
shouldn't be protected from liability
should we do this by saying you know
they're really publishers not not
platforms should we do this by saying
that they're monopoly should we do this
by saying that they're committing fraud
and he said yes
all of the above but we should do it
because if you control speech in a
republic you control the whole political
order so yeah we should use the
government
to against our political opponents who
have a lot of political power in big
tech that's just
common sense from caitlyn hey michael
question for you how many kids is too
many i'm the youngest of four kids our
parents are divorced in the hustle of
shuffling between mom and dad the
consistency of always having my siblings
was comforting i was talking about this
with my sister somewhat recently she's
the eldest sibling and she shared that
she has some resentment for having to
take on parenting roles while still a
child herself both of our parents worked
and so she had to fill in the gaps
especially with me i'm now married and
have two children my husband and i have
always had the good old catholic
approach however many children the good
lord will bless us with i want to make
sure i am available to provide for
emotional and physical needs and they
don't need to get that from their
siblings
i'm not saying i want to be like 19 kids
and counting but i don't want to be done
it too sincerely
i don't want to be the reason my kids
need therapy
yeah keep having kids be open to life
it's great
it's great you know why not
the problem that you and your siblings
had is not that you had too many
siblings and you said that's a great
great comfort the problem is that your
parents got divorced
and actually the number of siblings was
a great comfort for you so i would i
would do it i would say more there are
going to be some downsides you won't be
able to pay as much attention to every
kid and you won't be able to buy them
christmas presents that are quite as
expensive but
so what you have a good big family and
if you
keep the family together it's a great uh
it's a great
gift you can have you know
i'm i
have a small fan i
come from a small family myself sweet
little elise and i are working on
growing our family you know it's great
great deal of fun to work on that sort
of thing and we'd like to and we're just
going to remain open to life and have as
many kids as we can but my father comes
from a big family you know he's got five
siblings and
which used to be considered a small
catholic family now it's considered a
gigantic family and it's great and it's
just a wonderful thing and i think uh
the siblings are all really grateful for
one another and we you know who are in
the next generation are really grateful
for it it's it's uh
it's worth a lot more than you know
nicer christmas presents or something i
think you really can't can't put a price
on how wonderful it is to have a big
family from ali my dearest favorite
podcaster my question to you is in
regard to female sports after the
laughable wnba parade i had to ask what
are your thoughts on the low viewership
of female sports mostly basketball
because the other ones are all right to
watch
but specifically do you think that
networks like espn shoving them down our
throats is hurting them at all are not
affecting it because they're lame on
their own the wnba will never be popular
so do you think it should just cease to
exist or should we just allow them to
play and ignore the left's attempt to
make it equal to men's sports sincerely
they need to stop trying to make fetch
happen yeah it's not
cool at all and the only reason
you hear about it even is because they
make a big political stink about it and
force the nba to subsidize it and then
as you say that the network's trying to
push it on you but even so no one shows
up to the parades right so
uh yeah sports are for physical
excellence
so
generally as a rule
people are only going to watch men's
sports there are some exceptions to this
they're you know they're going to watch
women's gymnastics right they're going
to watch women's ice skating they're
going to well there are certain sports
that that
but i don't do you even call that really
a sport it's certainly an athletic feat
but so you're gonna watch things
where you're watching the greatest
displays of physical excellence and so
in some cases that can be women but in
the vast majority of sports it's going
to be
men
and uh i guess the one exception i would
say to this is in tennis but i think
that's really just because of the
celebrity of the williams sisters i
don't know that people would really care
that much about women's tennis if not
for them they they really became a big
big celebrity uh
uh couple
not like not a couple like they're
dating but you know the two of them
really help popularize that sport but
yeah in general people are not going to
pay attention to it so i don't you know
i couldn't name
wnba players and i don't pay any
attention to it at all and i say this is
someone without really a dog in the
fight because i've never been the most
athletic fella in the world but if i am
going to watch sports i want to watch
as everyone does we want to watch the
best and the strongest and the fastest
and
just as a fact of biology that is going
to be men
from quade
hello smokey mike hello hello quade
i was wondering what your opinion on how
secularization in europe from 1500
onward contributed to society my one
university class is requiring a final
paper on how secularization was what
drove the success of europe i got
permission from my professor to argue
that it was not secularization but
rather the fulfillment of
judeo-christian values that drove the
success of europe and that
secularization was what led to the
atrocities of the 20th century in the
decline of europe i was wondering what
resources you would recommend to best
argue my position thanks a canadian
who escaped to florida well i think your
position is a little confused because
you're you're talking about the great
success of europe after 1500
but you're then focusing then then you
have to explain away the lack of success
you know then you have to explain away
the atrocities
so i guess the first question you have
to ask is
is europe's great success
post 1500
i don't really think it is i think that
this is a line of argument that is
argued by
woke people
and secularists and liberals and
protestants to some degree because
you'll notice what happened in 1517 was
the beginning of the protestant
revolution and so i think as a result of
that
uh
first protestants and then liberals and
then secularists had to rewrite history
to say that everything before 1500 was
really bad and it was filled with the
dark ages and people who didn't know
anything and a lot of that was just
completely made up but you think about
the greatest works of art
and the greatest contributions
to
western civilization well i don't know
thomas aquinas that was before 1500 by a
lot right uh saint augustine that was a
long time before 1500.
dante alighieri that was a long time
before 1500 and
you know there were
a lot of wonderful artistic developments
afterward but i don't think they were a
major break
from the civilization before 1500.
actually a lot of it comes from the
counter-reformation right a lot of it
comes from artists like caravaggio or
rainey or you know other people who
created so much of the art and the
beautiful cathedrals and things that we
think of when we think of western
civilization so i
i would maybe make the argument that um
secularization
which i do think you know actually does
trace itself
to
the protestant revolution because it
cracks up the the confidence of europe
to to make truth claims and and leads to
liberalism
uh which then led to secularism which
has led to woke-ism i i think that
you you might make the argument that
secularization led to europe's downfall
and i think you might make the claim
that europe was actually a great deal
stronger before secularization began
from kathy hi michael love your show
thanks for all the great work you do i
have a question about a situation that's
come up at work recently
my company is requiring that i
participate in an interactive
unconscious bias training i want to be
better about speaking up in a way that's
authentic and true rather than staying
quiet or worse equivocating
not sure if this is the forum for this
but do you have any tips for how to
articulate reflections on this topic
from a conservative point of view i'm a
very facts first person so it's hard for
me to think about how to do this uh
in what is sure to be a feelings
oriented conversation thanks
sure it depends what what they bring up
to you um the issue with unconscious
bias
is if their argument is that you have
these unconscious biases but then once
they become conscious you can cure them
then you can say oh then you can just
judge them on the merits
is you know
are they really bringing up unconscious
prejudices i have
are those prejudices bad and what should
i do to fix them but usually what they
say is everyone has these unconscious
biases and prejudices and everyone's
racist all the white people are racist
but no other people cannot be racist you
can be a white person who doesn't
hate people on the basis of their race
you can be a black person who does hate
people on the basis of their race the
white guy will still be the racist and
the black guy will still not be the
racist
or the anti-racist or whatever so if
that's the case and they say well yeah
you can we can talk about these
unconscious biases but you can never fix
them then i would say well then what's
the point of the training
if there's nothing we can do about it
then what's the point of the training
would just be to
instill a sense of racial guilt you know
an irredeemable racial guilt so i would
i would avoid that and then i would
stand up against the claims that you
find false and i would be firm about
them you don't need to be flamboyant but
you you i would be firm and i think you
mostly need to be aware that that could
have professional consequences for you
and i i think you ought to have the
integrity and the courage to stand up
for them and do it in a way that's
prudent and you know wise as a serpent
and innocent as a dove
but you might have to face consequences
for it increasingly we all might have to
face consequences if we want to stand up
for what is good and true and beautiful
i'm michael nolsus the michael knowles
show see you on monday
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadofsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021 hey
everybody this is andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the is
collapsing the end of days is
approaching and the moons turn to blood
but on the andrew clavin show that's
where the fun just gets started so come
on over to the andrew clavin show and
laugh your way through the fall of the
republic with me andrew clavin